♪♪
Happy birthday, baby.
What do you think of your new boat?
I'll tell you when I actually step foot on it.
♪♪
Looks a little small.
The past few months
have been a dark time.
Molly
What are you doing in here?
♪♪
Hailey? In our bedroom?
I can explain.
Was she even born when we
graduated college
Actually she was 1.
Oooooh
Molly!
I want a divorce.
You never think stuff like this
is gonna happen to you.
But I'm much better now.
Hello
Molly Novack?
I'm the executive director of your foundation
My what?
I was wondering if you wouldn't mind
coming into the office tomorrow.
I have an office?
No.
Molly come in here girl.
We're not used to meeting celebrities.
I'm not a celebrity.
Yes you are.
You're like the most famous cheated on
woman on the planet.
Hi, there!
Let's be honest.
You only showed up today because you got divorced.
I never did the work
to find out who I am
It's really, really scary.
I'm sorry I don't really care about any of that.
Wow, when I said that to Oprah,
she gave me one of the biggest hugs.
What do you think about Molly's foundation?
It's a bit more
complicated than organizing a
cocktail party
I need to prove I have substance.
♪♪
I am so excited to
save the world together
See you tomorrow
and the next day
and the next day...
actually
Friday there's a thing in St. Bart's
I might wanna go to
but definitely next week.
Surprise!
Look at us.
Two new Besties.
Part of me wants to hate you Molly,
But you pull us together
and you made us better.
I think I'm gonna cry.
You got so much money you could buy any man.
Chris Hemsworth, Liam Hemsworth...
You could probably make you a whole new Hemsworth.
Oh my god. I need one of those.